through the razor wire stones thrown
over towards the polish border troops an
attack ostensibly by migrants but which
poland says was carried out under the
strict control of belarussian officials
met with all the tools of crowd control
that poland had standing by
water cannons firing deep into the
crowds clearing away the tents and
families who'd camped here hours before
volleys of tear gas and stun grenades
a major escalation after a frustrating
cold and frightening week for the
thousands of migrants stuck in limbo
between poland and belarus
when the fighting finished for most it
was back to the camp they call the
jungle the status quo unchanged
but as night fell a different prospect
for hundreds more
a huge warehouse cleared for the
migrants their faces filled with relief
and how good it must feel to clean off
the grime of the past few days to lie on
something that's not bare ground to be
able to feel your feet
fourteen-year-old ahmed spent 11 days at
the border with his family and
one-year-old brother
my finger not worth in not work in
jungle because so-called i my brother
if he die what i am doing
maybe tonight is die but i'm come here
and
my life right now is safe i i don't know
for after
and what happens now
i don't know but we go
my country
going back home to iraq yeah yeah i go
to
so has everyone here said that they'll
go back home yes everyone here
will be back
there's a flight back this thursday and
a lot of people here will be on it their
dreams shattered
this is certainly a whole lot better
than spending another night out in the
freezing cold and it is probably also
the result of diplomatic pressure with
both the german chancellor and the
russian president calling alexander
lukashenko over the last 24 hours he may
not be universally recognized as
legitimate but he has certainly managed
to prove a point
but what role have these balaclava bella
russians played there are reports of
beatings back at the camp people
pressured to fight the polish border
guards and the belarusian security
forces do not have a good track record
and for all the hundreds here there are
thousands more still at the border still
desperate to cross
still at the mercy of the elements and
of an autocrat's whims
dynamagnay sky news at the belarussian
polish border